[Music]
hey there guys and gals welcome to
another episode of this podcast I'm your
host Medina and today we're diving into
a topic that's close to my heart Teen
Mental Health we know that high school
can be a challenging time for many teens
and mental health is a topic that
deserves our attention we're going to
talk about what's messing with our head
in high school and more importantly how
we can keep our sanity intact High
School is a jungle and I'm here to help
you navigate it so let's kick things off
with the elephant in the room High
School is tough no doubt about it we're
juggling classes homework tests and all
the social drama it's like a 247 soap
opra other than that there's peer
pressure and let's not forget those
awkward changes going on in our bodies
these struggles can mess with our heads
and it's totally normal to not feel our
best at times so what's cooking in the
pot of teen mental health issues let's
dish it out the classic pressure cooker
parental expectations it's like our
folks are cooking up a big pot of be
perfect toew it's tough and it's okay to
admit it but here's the deal they love
you and they want what's best for you
but sometimes they might not understand
the pressure you're under
it's important to have those heart-to-
heart talks with them then there's
academic pressures the Relentless
pursuit of top grades and the fear of
not meeting expectations can lead to
stress anxiety and even
depression it's crucial to remember that
it's okay to ask for help when you're
feeling overwhelmed I get it greats
matter but it can feel like the weight
of the world when you've got assignments
piling up that can turn anyone into a
stress ball no one needs that that and
oh my God bullying folks it's like the
villain in our high school story whether
it's physical verbal or online it's a
total buzz kill and then there's bad
friends yeah we've all had a taste of
those they're like a cloud of negativity
following you around toxic friendships
can suck the joy out of your life but
remember you do deserve better peer
relationships can play a significant
role in a team mental well-being
bullying peer pressure and the desire to
fit in can all take a toll open
communication with friends and family is
essential to navigate these
challenges then there's social media
that's one spicy ingredient we're glued
to our screens comparing Our Lives to
those perfect insta feeds it's a one-way
ticket to feeling down about ourselves
it can even lead you to feelings of
anxiety it's important to limit screen
time and remember that what you see on
social media doesn't reflect
reality and don't even get me started in
puberty it's like a hormonal explosion
one moment you're El the next you're in
the dumps we're all in this together and
it's like our emotions are playing a
game of ping pong it's a wild ride so
what can we do to keep our heads above
water firstly self-awareness is key
understanding your own emotions and
seeking help when needed is a sign of
strength not
weakness secondly good friends the real
MVPs they're your support system your
cheerleaders and the ones who bring out
your best self coping with all this
chaos isn't the solo Mission surround
yourself with people who lift you up who
understand your struggles and are there
to listen when you need it let's talk
about
communication communication is key don't
hesitate to reach out shout to a trusted
friend family member or concealer if
you're feeling overwhelmed remember
again it's a sign of strength not
weakness to seek for help and third
self-care it's not just a buzzword take
time for yourself whether it's reading
listening to music or just chilling out
your mental well-being deserves some
TLC last but not least know that it's
okay not to be okay we all have our off
days and that's fine but if it gets too
much seek professional help remember
there's no shame in asking for
professional help therapists and
concealers are there to guide you
through the messiness of growing up so
we understand that high school can be a
time of immense stress and change for
teenagers academic pressures social
dynamics and the process of
self-discovery can all contribute to the
mental health
challenges it's crucial for students
parents and Educators to be aware of
signs that a teen might be struggling
with their mental health keep an eye out
for changes in Behavior such as
withdrawal from Friends declining grades
and mood swings these can be indicators
of underlying issues encouraging open
communication and reducing the stigma
around mental health is crucial also
schools should create safe spaces for
students to express
themselves before we wrap it up let's
get real te mental health is like an
Epic Quest and there's no cheat code to
win it but by talking about it we're
already leveling up you are stronger
than you think more resilient than you
can imagine High School might be a
battlefield but it's also where
Discovery
superpowers thank you so much for
joining us on this episode of high
school memories it's been an incredible
journey and we're so glad you came along
for the ride until next time take care
here